just like the witcher 3 there are
certain quest lines in cyberpunk 2077
you'll want to finish before the credits
roll we've put together a list of some
of the most important quests you should
complete before you embark on that final
battle if you're curious when that final
battle is
don't worry the game will hit you with a
point of no return message before you
start it
lastly there will be some spoilers in
this video particularly regarding
romance
options so keep that in mind and of
course don't forget to like and
subscribe for more cyberpunk 2077 videos
alright let's get started
god how mundane no idea scabs and skies
of scratch
you happy heroes this side quest wraps
up some of the threads left hanging in
act 1 of the main story
after the events of the heist tell
delamane to return to jackie's family's
home
you'll later receive a call from his
mother mama wells to start the quest
heroes isn't an essential item there are
no major rewards other than a nice
motorcycle
and it won't affect your ending it will
however close off the
early portion of the story in a
satisfying way and expand on your
relationship with key characters from
act 1
and early act 2 who will be part of the
endgame missions later on
let's move on to judy's questline you'll
have the opportunity to grow your
relationship with judy after you
complete the main quest
automatic love the next three quests
both sides now
x factor and talking about a revolution
concern judy's plan to free clouds from
the influence of its bosses and the
tiger claw
gang to advance judy's quest make sure
to volunteer to help her and support her
in her ideas
after you've made plans to liberate
clouds you'll head up to a tigerclaw
penthouse in a mission called pisces to
try to convince them to leave the
business alone how you make your way
through the mission is up to you
but the choices you make at the end
affect where your relationship goes with
judy who
is a possible romance partner judy is
only attracted to characters with
feminine bodies and voices so keep
that in mind you'll also either need to
buck maiko's plan and return control of
the class to the dolls or assist mico
and resist her payment at the end of the
mission
pyramid song also gives you your chance
to romance judy while unlocking her
apartment as a safe house
for your use from there on out everyone
in this city lives in their own goddamn
bubble
and either you fly high or sink into
quicksand
next up is pan ams questline once you
complete ghost town and life during
wartime in the main story quest you'll
eventually get a call from pan am
asking for additional help you'll need
to rescue a nomad from a raf and
scavenger camp for the first mission
then help pan am with a heist
make sure you side with pan am and any
arguments about what the right course of
action is or you might end the quest
line
early if you stay on pan am side you can
eventually unlock the opportunity to
start a romance with her although she's
only attracted to characters with
masculine body and voice types
if you want to complete pan am's romance
quest be sure to flirt with her during
riders on the storm by recommending she
remove her shoes and don't tip off saul
to her plan in with a little help from
my friends
you should also avoid suggesting that
you're helping pan am for monetary
reasons
you'll also get your chance to
consummate the relationship in queen of
the highway while also
opening up a safe house in the aldo
caldo camp for your use
completing pan am's relationship quest
even if you don't choose to romance her
can
also have an effect on the ending you
get without my clan who am i
what would i become if i stayed in night
city next up is rivers questline
to kick off rivers series of character
quests you'll need to complete ghost
town and life during wartime and also
raise your street cred specifically in
haywood
city center or westbrook you'll soon get
a call from elizabeth perales which will
give you the opportunity to take on a
side job i fought the law
taking on the quest will put you in
contact with river another major side
character and possible romance partner
after completing i fought the law you'll
eventually receive another call from
river asking for your help on another
job
you'll need to help him on his
investigation into an accused kidnapper
known as peter pan
the goal of the mission is to track down
randy river's nephew which takes you on
a multi-step quest to gather information
the primary piece of info you're trying
to track down is peter pan's hideout
you can do this just by putting together
clues or by tracking down randy's
computer if your intelligence attribute
is high enough
if you find the right clues river will
take you to the correct farm
straight away if not you'll have to
guess picking the wrong farm however can
lock you out of river's romance option
if you have to guess the correct farm is
edgewood the final mission in river's
quest gives you the chance to solidify
the romance but he'll only be attracted
to you if you've got a female body type
and if you've managed to save randy's
life
the last mission is just story and
conversations but allow you to complete
rivers storyline
relax just got one question to ask you
and now we're on to johnny's questline
you'll unlock his first quest chipping
in once you've completed
four major branches of story missions
automatic love with judy
life during war time with pan am
transmission with the voodoo boys and
search and destroy with takamura the
conversations with johnny that take
place after
those missions compose tapeworm a side
quest that opens up a number of missions
related to johnny's life
chipping in is the beginning of johnny's
questline so you'll want to knock that
one out for sure
head to the afterlife to kick it off and
allow johnny to take control while
you're there
completing this quest earns you johnny's
extremely powerful pistol
and can also get you his porsche if you
spare grayson's life toward the end of
the mission
to unlock the rest of the missions be
sure to choose friendly dialogue options
with johnny during the quest wrap
up the rest of the quests in this chain
depend on becoming friends with johnny
ready to thrash lastly let's talk about
carrie's questline
as with other side character quests
carries covers several missions
and if you meet the right requirements
can end up in a romance you'll need to
be a masculine v to be carrie's type
none of the missions are particularly
difficult or involve much
action they're primarily about
conversations in boat drinks make sure
to kiss carrie when the opportunity
arises and tell him to pencil me in when
you talk to carrie on the beach that'll
solidify the relationship
and now you just pop by the [ __ ] all
over my life
well i'mma lose my damn mind
and to close this out it's worth noting
that most of these quest lines will
directly affect the ending and your
final choices but if there are other
quests that stand out to you let us know
in the comments below
for more cyberpunk 2077 make sure to
subscribe to the channel
see you next time
[Music]
you